again 16 welcome to Blood Bowl to a
smashingly violent marriage between the
Warhammer world and American football
this brutal turn-based strategy game has
been upgraded with a new graphics engine
full team customization and of assistant
multiplayer with a slew of new online
features the goal is simple receive the
kick off outsmart the opposing coach
manage the risks and score as many
touchdowns as possible
players of different positions stats and
skills and it's up to their coaches to
optimize their abilities using
positioning and strategy Blood Bowl 2
has a full single-player campaign where
players take the role of a new coach
hired by the right and Reva's as they
struggle to regain their former titles
the campaign matches the whole sorts of
wild and unexpected events constantly
renewing the gameplay so prepare to
manage your players recruit the best and
not so brightest and fix up your stadium
to bring the crowds in the glory on the
multiplayer side manage your very own
fully customized teams from eight races
representing the Warhammer world the per
level Inhumans the brutal orcs the
sturdy dwarves the Swift Skaven
the proud high elves the merciless dark
elves the destructive beasts of the
chaos and the brand-new Britannia they
will soon be joined by two extra races
the wood elves and the lizard men the
players will first get through
pre-ordering each race as their own
characteristics and features skilled
star pairs for hire whose extraordinary
skills and abilities will definitely
help you turn the tide of the match
upgrade your stadium and level up by
gaining XP to unlock new skills but be
careful on deaths are permanent and
losses a final play online in
multiplayer leagues or play an
exhibition match with a friend locally
if you're interested in managing your
own league it's possible within Blood
Bowl 2 s competition creator another
addition to the Blood Ball franchise is
the online marketplace where coaches can
buy or sell their players with one
another want to get rid of that Blitzer
who doesn't match the rest of the team
and make some gold and trade him in lost
a talented lineman during a freak
basement accident find your next MVP in
the market so or DSA coach can you lead
your team to become the next Blood Bowl
champion coming September on ps4 Xbox
one and PC